- Did you ever, I heard,
this could be a joke,
but did you write into Playboy for advice,
like career advice?
- Yeah.
- And what kind of career opportunity
was one looking for writing into Playboy?
- I was a desperate young guy.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- Yeah, I didn't know what
to do with my musical life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so,
I saw this thing in Playboy magazine.
My stepfather, I guess,
used to buy it, and I sent.
- You just outed him, I like it, yeah.
- So, I sent a letter
saying, "I have an offer
"to go on the road with a girl singer.
"I play piano and in order to do that,
"I had to leave my job
at CVS as the mail boy."
- Which is steady work.
- [Barry] Which one should I do?
- Yeah.
- And they wrote me
back and they printed it
and they said, "Take the job outside
"and follow your musical notes."
- Oh, I love that.
- And I did, I left.
- You left and you did it.
- I left CVS.
- So, really you have Playboy
to thank for everything.
- I do.
I do, yeah.
- So I know that you and Bette
worked together quite a bit,
so, and did she help you
promote your first album?
- Well, yes.
She let me, I was her music
director and conductor
and the arranger.
And we went on the road together.
And I had this first album
and I didn't wanna leave her.
And so, she was very generous.
She let me open her second act.
So, instead of her coming out.
- Yeah.
- The piano player came out,
and that was crazy.
The audience didn't want
see the piano player
singing three songs.
I know that.
But again, they were very kind.
Bette's audiences were very kind to me
and they let me do three songs,
and it was the beginning
of my performing career.
- Wow, I think you're right though.
I do think audiences love.
I have my band do that
sometimes, like come in and out.
I think they do love seeing
artists support other artists.
I think that's a big, a big thing.
- Well, she was great to let me do that.
- Yeah.
- Then I actually did take
off on my own and here I am.
- I know, and then she was like, "Crap,
"I shouldn't have let him sing.
"I lost my musical director."
- Yeah, you're right.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's amazing.
So wait.
- She never forgave me.
- But you, I love it.
She's like, "Where the hell did you go?"